[Music]
investigators say those gunshots early
in the morning last september led them
to discover something else inside this
northwest valley garage
police say the man in this video holding
the gun is 27 year old lacey walther he
had reported an attempted car burglary
here on cabo creek court he confronted
the thief and called 9-1-1 we're going
to go ahead and send someone over to
talk to you make sure the gun is put
away now okay
do they need to see it should i give it
to them
no just for now just keep it put away
but we'll send someone over to contact
you they're already in the area looking
around okay
all right evidence obtained by the
i-team and shown to a grand jury reveal
investigators went inside the home
looking for that gun but inside they
found much more a stash of explosives
and other items they say could be used
for terror a painting of osama bin laden
on the wall with one man's terrorist is
another man's freedom fighter written in
arabic investigators also found a 3-d
printer to make guns components to build
ieds which an investigator noted looked
like what foreign terror groups make to
target our military overseas counter
terrorism detectives finding a notebook
they say included recipes to make bombs
in other homemade devices one page talks
about government unrest and chemicals
for the eyes other pages include how to
make a letter bomb and a list of
poisonous plants
so i asked metro if walther wanted to
talk to us from jail hear his side of
the story he agreed to do that but said
we would have to pay him five thousand
dollars and denise you know we don't pay
people for interviews of course so is is
there any indication by the looks of
these photos and the police report that
maybe this guy was planning something
specific so there's nothing in the
reports that say there was anything no
evidence that metro writes or was given
to the grand jury that anything was
planned although investigators say all
signs simply point that he certainly was
in the process
of carrying something out though what
that is we don't know detectives just
grateful that they caught this in time
for what could have been something much
worse very interesting report all right
david thanks for that tonight
we have posted all the photos by the way
from this case online for you you can
see the slideshow on 8newsnow.com also
inside of our free app the link is right
there on our homepage